kind sober and fully dressed good news
everyone we found the name of santiago
sex tape
what is all this no i think halloween is
for jerks well this halloween i was the
jerk
i'm sorry about tonight
i'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for santiago's follow-up sex tape
i'm sorry i couldn't convince you to
love halloween it's not your fault i was
terrible it's not your fault i was
terrible it's also one of your sex tapes
[Music]
halloween is unbearable
but
it was slightly less unbearable with you
don't why did you get it so big
a that's what she said
jim no thanks i'm good
that's what she said
mom
uh my mother's coming that's what she
said
does the skin look red and swollen
that's what she said that's my joke damn
it dwight
that's what she said
i don't get it
grapes seductive how about the phyllis
angela dispute you already did me that's
what she said
i can't
stay on top of you 24 7.
oh this is so cool you can shoot around
corners
i love guns i'm gonna make such a good
dad not even gonna touch that the amy
santiago story all right the linoleum
awaits my dear
oh boy
i know we're undercover but i'm starting
to get real nervous about this contest
you need to see a therapist
let's dance this way
oh how did you manage to step on both of
my feet at the same time i'm horrible at
this when can we stop i'm horrible at
this one no i know title of my sex tape
yeah well done title of my sex tape
and the best way to start is to hit
start
and up comes
the tool bar that's what she said
hey
can you make that straighter
that's what she said
did you plan that
no
can you make that straighter
that job looks hard
you should put your mouth on that
how can you even use that one naturally
blowing up balloons i thought
eat it eat it phyllis dip it in the
water so it'll slide down your gullet
more easily
oh no no no not that's just come on you
guys let's do it i need two men on this
that's what she said no time but she did
no time i want to give you something oh
that's what she said
okay you know what i want you to think
about your future at this company i want
you to think about it long and hard
that's what she said
don't you dare
i'll be your first customer you're
hardly my first
there's a season
hey
got your drink thanks
what is this champagne mixed with 30
year old scotch and top shelf tequila
captain said a two drink max but he did
not set a price limit smort
oh god it's horrible yeah i shouldn't
have added the olive juice ew
hey so listen the thing i said you
before i went undercover about how i
wish something had happened between us
romantically
that wasn't nothing that was real
what are you saying
i know that you're with teddy i'm not
trying to change that and i get there
stuff i can't control but this morning i
told you that i didn't mean any of it
and that was a lie
i just don't want to hold anything back
well thank you for saying that
just as long as we're clear that i'm
with someone and nothing is gonna happen
unless someone nothing's gonna happen
name your sex tape
he's back
go
force it in as deep as you can
i'm glad of today's spurred social
change that's part of my job as regional
manager but you know what even if it
didn't
at least we put this matter to bed
that's what she said
or he
said they kept hiring from the outside
it was easy to get in but impossible to
rise up
that's what she
a lot of places are like that
one more bite of eclair each hold it in
your mouth if you can't swallow
really nothing
hello you
michael hey buttercup i am on my way
should be there about 15.
party up that's what she said
why is this so hard
that's what she said
oh my god what am i saying
dwight get out of my nook that's what
she said that's what she said that's
what she said
good one
where's the band
cause there's no way you guys are making
this magic with just your mouths
ten years you'll figure it out
well i don't think i'll be here in ten
years but
that's what i said
that's what she said
that's what who's that
i never know
i just say it
i say stuff like that you know
it's a lighting attention
when things sort of get hard that's what
she said
hey nice i did something really stupid i
need your help
you know i'm kind of a sexy bad boy who
rides motorcycles into work and is
always breaking the rules in the name of
justice i don't like where this is going
well i also maybe sometimes bring home
case files to work on them after hours
and i might not be that great about
returning them oh god are you aroused
because of what a bad boy i am no no you
could be suspended for that he could
think you're the molest you're not so
loud yes amy i do drink from the bowl
definitely pulled that off look i need
to get those vials can you please give
me a ride fine i'll get my stuff but
this bedroom not bite me in the ass
better not bite me in the ass name of
your sex tape but seriously thank you so
much for your help
santiago diaz before you go both of you
requested to have this saturday off but
i need one of you to work oh i could
take that shift the last time you worked
on saturday you watched cartoons the
entire time well that's when you're on
work this out and get back to me
sorry
i can't reschedule i have tickets to a
ted talk on power poses and getting what
you want by using your body
uh-oh i hope it doesn't get too sexual
uh-oh i hope it doesn't get too sexual
title your sex tape but seriously what
is taking so long also the title of your
sex tape this is huge that's what she
said
sold for 300 to me
the hell is that it's the only gavel i
could find it squeaks when you bang
that's what she said ah
oscar would you reach over and touch his
thing that's what he said right guys
because of gay
how long have you known ms levinson six
years and two months and you were
directly under her the entire time
that's what she said excuse me that's
what she said ms levinson told you that
she was your direct superior
well what
why would she say that can we just move
on to another question no wait i don't i
don't understand who's on record is
saying this with all due respect i'm in
the middle of the line of questioning
now mr scott what did you say miss
levinson said regarding your employment
status with respect to her corporate
position
come again that's what she said i don't
know what you're talking about if i may
he he was just telling a joke before so
can we move on to another question are
you sure uh yes
can you go back to where this digression
began
mr schneider and you were directly under
her the entire time mr scott that's what
she said
well
delivery's all wrong he's butchering it
you need to get back on top
that's what she said
yeah yeah
your office is full of genitalia
uh-oh iso is located l
that's what he says damn it i never
recommended you because i didn't want to
lose you and then while it was pam
but no i don't want to lose the baby so
instead you screwed me
that's your cheese no
geek blast of cold air coming out of
that box name of amy's sex tape hey man
come on not cool i'm going through
something just let me have this one
we'll crack it i'm gonna go grab some
coffee great
hey uh now that it's just us there's a
thing i wanted
to say i does uh you
why doesn't your mouth work why doesn't
your mouth work title of our sex tape
your sex tape what no ah
sorry i think
i'm feeling a little awkward yeah me too
how do we make it not weird
i know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well ah i like your style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light and breezy
so
we broke a rule
yeah
i hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape
title of our sex tape
you